well it is back the johnson johnson
vaccine or jansen as it's known
is available again in nevada after a
brief pause because of several cases
where
people reported with blood clots it was
rare but still severe for those people
health officials are hoping for the
community's trust when it comes to
vaccination
christian casadas joining us live in the
studio with more on how they hope to
achieve this christian
well denise that trust is key to getting
through this pandemic and reopening
nevada health officials
say they are searching for community
champions to help spread the word
now this effort involves working hand in
hand with community organizations
and coalitions to gain the public's
trust on vaccination
they are working to get everyone on
board to reach the 60 percent benchmark
of eligible clark county residents
vaccinated with at least
one dose of the covet 19 vaccine shot
not only are they focusing on the
unvaccinated population
but also on those in need of their
second shot
texting email having providers send out
reminders to those they've vaccinated
and then just working on the broad media
campaign
three million reasons and all of that as
well just to make sure they get the
message that getting that full
protection
getting that second dose if you've got
modern or pfizer is very important
the johnson johnson vaccine is back in
circulation
in the state the vaccine was put on
pause for more than a week
after cases of rare blood clocks were
reported in six women
one of them from right here in nevada
now doses from that manufacturer resumed
on saturday as for covid restrictions
well they're rolling back
health officials expect an increase in
cases but
they are unclear right now as to what
that will look like they hope
to regain people's trust and for
everyone to basically go out and get
vaccinated sooner than later
christian casadas 8 news now